à m sila il m'appelle adepte si la
caisse qui la suit si salah comment ça
va commencer il est leader incroyable
talent hier où et c'est une émission n'a
que des amis sache le mais je ne le
connais pas je te remplacer mais j'ai
toujours courtois tu es toujours
courtois boucan pour faire très très
court parce que mademoiselle satie dès à
présent qu'elle passe à apprendre de
celle ci car est dans les petits papiers
alors connaissant même si là que je
côtoie qui tape vraiment à tout ça
devrait pas appeler s'ils s'étaient
inscrits non c'était surtout et comment
dirais-je les candidats l'heureux leurs
passages dans les émissions d'avant
adacore briser un petit peu avec bien
sûr et à bosser en fait mon coeur je
dois dire à la protéger de tels coups
coeur tels couture telles couture et
après pendant l'émission
je peux changer de colton besoin il me
dit ok tu restes sur ton golden buzzer
qui resteront tout
pourtant cold and other il leur dit oui
et pourquoi il est beau il est sans
défaut
je sais que ça a fait un peu polémique
c'est parce qu'en fait les mecs ils
n'ont pas eu grand chose
il avait tellement envie les autres
c'était prix y avait beaucoup de
professionnels mais il avait tellement
c'est tellement vie tellement ri et
c'était en fait cette émission c'est
vraiment un coup de pouce parce que
c'est ce qui n'est plus le coup de pouce
et au lavabo il va faire du buzz sur les
notes partout même dans les lavabos
paraît il à faire des spectacles
je me suis vu danser dans cette zone là
et ça fait bizarre on dirait que j'ai 45
ans ou bien tu es bientôt bien notre
intérêt pour tout cas ce n'est pas
fatigué
aucun mot chéri on t'envoie des
prétoires mon âme est de taille mais
revient de voir les comptes andré
vauchez voilà c'est là
m